welcome back everybody it might be cool
outside right now but that's not going
to last much longer which is why don
mccarthy
beauty and lifestyle advisor of dawn's
corner is sharing four products we
need to add to our summer prep list take
a look hello las vegas now
happy may this month in addition to
getting us ready for the unofficial
kickoff to summer
it's also the month we celebrate nurses
so i would like to introduce to all the
nurses out there
moxie scrubs it's the first
direct-to-consumer brand
for nurses by nurses keeping comfort
and functionality a priority born out of
harvard's innovation lab
each moxie product is named after the
nurse
who created the innovative designs their
patent-pending comfort panel
adds an additional layer of softness and
sizing is offered from extra small
to 3x petite and tall
go to moxiescrubs.com for more
information and a huge thank you to all
the nurses
who went above and beyond this past year
now keeping with health and wellness
child life essentials has been around
for the past
20 years their vitamins and supplements
for children are made with
pure natural and safe ingredients
with all naturally tasty fruit
flavorings
their daily core essentials help with
brain
bone immune and overall health in
children
and their soft melt gummies have zero
sugar
both supplements will support your
child's immune system going into the
summer
and right now you can also purchase at
amazon.com
child life and using code i heart cl
you'll get twenty percent off so go
ahead and add that to your cart
these last two products i consider to be
my
white t-shirt beauty products as they
work on
everyone at any age first
i have chirp this is the first time this
has even been seen on tv
chirps patented technology combines
sonic oscillation
and rotation into an awesome poor
cleansing
dirt busting makeup removing device that
works for men and women
this is truly like the dyson of facial
devices
the sonic oscillations loosens the dirt
and debris from deep within the pores
while the gentle rotation removes the
debris and exfoliates the skin
chirp has 100 yes 100 completely unique
cleansing combinations to choose from
while other competing devices either
just spin or vibrate
chirp does both and at any speed you
desire perfectly blended together
to get one for you or father's day is
next month
go to churchproducts.com and lastly
body coverage perfector is mine and
hollywood's best kept secret
for having flawless looking skin color
body coverage perfector is the
first of its kind body camouflage and
illuminator
all in one for flawless radiant looking
skin
this full coverage formula with tri
effects technology
is easy to apply and instantly conceals
everything from veins
to age spots to the darkest tattoos but
it looks natural and is clinically shown
to be waterproof
transfer resistant and can even last up
to a few days
i have personally not gone on camera for
the past five years
without having this on and it's a
must-have
going into the summer months get yours
today
at westmorebeauty.com and i actually
like the natural radiance color but they
have a color for all skin tones
for more information on any of these
products featured
visit donscorner.com